this is a CBS News special report I'm
Anthony Mason in New York the Labor
Department has just released its newest
weekly unemployment report it shows
millions more Americans have lost their
job for the seventh straight week in
this corona virus pandemic CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger joins
us now Jill what are the latest numbers
we've got just more than 3.1 million
Americans who filed for new claims and
this is the seventh straight week of
claims we now top 33 million Americans
who have filed for claims you know the
numbers and the pace have certainly been
kind of slowing down but when you think
about three million Americans who are
filing for unemployment that is just a
sad and staggering number I guess the
best that can be said is it's a little
less worse than it was back at the end
of March and beginning of April yeah
it's I mean three million doesn't look
good it looks a little better than what
we've seen before Jill but we're we're
seeing we're seeing some really stunning
losses in the private sector now what's
happening there well ADP reported
yesterday that private payrolls were
down by more than 20 million in a single
month now this is not a report that's
been in use for that long but going back
to 2002 this trounces the previous
record I think there were maybe 800,000
in a single month previously the job
losses are spread across the services
and the goods-producing sector but
services more we're a service economy 16
million jobs lost in the services
economy 4 million in goods producing
like manufacturing and construction of
course the places you would expect to
see it leisure and hospitality retail
professional and business services it is
a widespread financial economic disaster
that has been caused by this pandemic
obviously not as important as the health
pandemic but hurting so many people
happening yeah so many facing either job
losses or pay cuts Jill who
in particular groups being hit hardest
here well if we got some new research
out from pew that shows a real
difference among black Hispanic and
white Americans Hispanics being hurt
most significantly 61% by the Hispanics
being hurt about 44 percent black
Americans compared with 38 percent white
Americans and I think the problem
becomes compounded because when we look
at this same set of research it finds
that the Hispanic and black Americans
have much lower emergency reserve funds
and so that's going to see them be hurt
financially longer and more
significantly all right Jill Schlesinger
thanks so much Jill once again more
discouraging news 3.1 million Americans
filing unemployment claims in the past
week tomorrow morning we'll be watching
the release of the Labor Department's
monthly jobless report for April it will
pinpoint the country's skyrocketing
unemployment rate caused by the corona
virus as we've been discussing our
coverage will continue on our 24-hour
streaming network cbsn you can watch it
at CBS news.com or on our CBS news app